and action addison ray is officially
making her acting debut
playing the lead in netflix's new movie
he's all that
it's really exciting i'm i'm ready
just wait until i'm done with his
makeover
he's definitely not what i expected
[Music]
on wednesday netflix dropped the trailer
which is a reimagining of the 1999
classic
she's all that starring rachel lee cook
and freddie prince jr
i'll pick the girl and you got six weeks
to turn her into the prom queen
gentlemen we have a winner hey you call
off the bet you lose
i don't lose so lanny listen i was
wondering if maybe you'd want to
embarrass me horribly from all these
people
but this time their roles are gender
swapped with her co-star tanner buchanan
playing
anti-social camera i don't want to stare
at your underwear while i eat
dirt bags meanwhile addison plays a
popular
influencer which isn't really too far
off for the tick tock star
who has over 80 million followers
we're live here in surprise we're on the
set of my boyfriend's brand new music
video
jordan what are you doing okay let's not
freak out
in january e.t visited addison and
tanner on set of the film
and they revealed if they felt pressure
living up to the beloved original movie
i do but i don't because there is a lot
of differences so i feel like it's not
too exact it's not like we're literally
remaking the first movie
yeah and it's not line for line and
that's a thing too is i think
coming in we have we have the essence of
the original but we're also creating
something new
so i think it's something that is all
around gonna make
everyone that was fans of the original
very very happy but bringing in all the
new eyes to it is also going to make
them very very happy
so i think the pressure's there but it
also too i think we know what we made
and we're very happy with it
something new we'll definitely get to
see in the remake is addison's close pal
kourtney kardashian
who plays her best friend jessica who's
the new guy a little scruffy but cute
and of course we'll see some familiar
faces from the original
like matthew lillard who played brock
hudson hey
i'm back at hey brock
hudson and rachel lee cook who played
the lead role as lady boggs
returns for the remake as addison's
on-screen mom
breakups are hard i was humiliated
you're going viral
in the wrong way it will get better what
was it like to have her
play your mom yeah that was really fun
it was really interesting i like
didn't know what to expect when she had
came on set and i got to talk to her
about how she played the role you know
of lainey even though it was the reverse
of mine but i feel like it kind of let
me connect
even more what did she tell you i mean
she really just was telling me
how she went through the role and her
way of kind of
communicating that to me was through
letting me know
like here's how i felt in these scenes
because
freddie did this you know and kind of
like let me know the way
they their relationship was on this like
on screen and while we'll always have a
soft spot in our hearts for laney and
zach
i feel just like julia robertson pretty
woman you know except for the whole
hooker thing
now it's time to celebrate paget and
cameron
things with pageant may have gotten a
little more complicated than i thought
[Music]